Taylor I got your email have a seat
I don't if you heard but someone stole
my lunch today that's horrible
who would do such a thing who would do
such a thing I have witnesses that can
put you at the scene of the crime Jason
you know you're getting quite the
reputation around here do you remember
Claudia's cupcakes that went missing
about three weeks ago yeah I remember oh
you remember that how about all the
cupcake wrappers that showed up in your
trash can someone gave this to me I
didn't know they were stolen right where
were you at 12:00 11:00 p.m. today at my
desk and who might have seen you at your
desk Mike and uh Jason Jason Jason I
have time for this okay I'm gonna be a
real hangry you don't want to see me I
get angry I didn't do it take a look at
these do you know these are oh my god
that's the contents of my lunch Oh God
what's wrong you a little queasy I can't
look
so full
where's my lunch hey sorry to bother you
but I think I accidentally grabbed your
back oh no worries yes thank you welcome
hey Jason have you seen my water boy